hey everyone hey and welcome back to the
third edition of watching The Watchmen
thank you so much for joining us if you
are returning we really appreciate that
if you're a new listener just a quick
bit of background here it's myself and
definition we are going through Watchmen
you know in my opinion probably the
greatest graphic novel ever written very
surprised there isn't like long-form
critical content there's a lot of
commentaries online in the form of
text-based things but there's no real
podcasts dig into this thing so you know
having a joy here I'm in a ball and I'm
gonna get into the third issue but a
deaf how's it going man
yeah I'm really ill today so excuse me
being an idiot and and just letting
everyone down but I'm so I'm sort of
like Janey Slater there's no new appears
in this episode some sort of method
podcasting right into it I like that I
like that and I'm you know I should say
as well you know wherever you're
listening to you've listened on youtube
subscribe doesn't iTunes vice-versa
leave us a review on iTunes you know
rubs you're available as a podcast on
there or on youtube subscribe to death's
channel comment send us an email as well
watching The Watchmen pod at gmail.com
you can get in touch with us there I've
seen a few people comment on the videos
as well which is great we wanna create a
bit of dialogue about this great thing
what are your interpretations of it what
do you think about our interpretations
of it what thoughts do you have on the
storyline on the characters where did
you get into Watchmen any of these
things you know me and definitely really
really interested to learn about that so
the best place is the email but obvious
you can comment as well and DEF um just
before we get into this issue you know I
know you're quite the appids reader any
good graphic novels you've read in the
past month or so yeah I definitely
recommend everyone check out all-star
Batman by Scott Snyder that's really
good
I've also been reading earth-2 and then
the new 52 run don't read that it's
terrible
and I've been reading the Justice League
new 52 run as well and that's really
really good so yeah they're all quite
cheap now because you know it's the
older generation um but but don't let it
don't let it slip you by because in ten
years time they'll probably be really
expensive again because they'll be out
of print and it's it's like when you get
you
Station two you know I mean when you
move with its PlayStation 3 all the
games were about fifty pence for the
PlayStation 2 you try and buy them now
they're dead expensive yeah they don't
let it slip you buy these don't
subscribe I am i I quite like the new 52
as well I haven't read too much of it I
think I signed you before Animal Man
which I read which is a brilliant
brilliant arc and it's interesting about
that the artist who drew it had to
retire because the art he was drawing
was making him feel ill because it's a
very sort of biological physical kind of
science comic and you know I I think a
lot about these DC movies I think if DC
made an animal man film they just need
to adapt the first three volumes of the
new 52 Animal Man it's a brilliant story
and it's like you know and yeah and I
need to check out Swamp Thing I think
that's the next thing I don't think
Scott Snyder wrote that as well as
Batman and obviously you know he's a
[ __ ] needs of a man crazy talent but
um yeah I want to recommend as well
I read black hammer Jeff lemierre's
black hammer which is kind of like
Watchmen it's kind of like a sort of
meta fast each take on superheroes we're
in this world basically there's this
kind of global event and this group of
superheroes are sent to this parallel
universe where they just live on this
farm in a small town America and they
can't escape and they kind of have to
adapt to normal society and it's good
it's not incredible but you know it's
not a bad read but I mean for me you
know the way I tend to read graphene on
was is I read authors that I liked you
know and Jeff Lemire who has done a lot
for the new 52 as well he did Animal Man
if indeed he Green Arrow and stuff like
that as well
I'm always interesting what that guy did
so the fact they did a new superhero
property I had to check it out but you
know as I say we're here for Watchmen
we're here for the third issue go back
check out our earlier editions as well I
think what clocked about three hours so
far on this thing and you know it's good
I'm sure it's gonna get longer we'll get
deeper into the story this is some the
judge of all the earth and as we always
start off death the cover talk to me how
to cover this issue it so it's a it's a
big yellow background with a
nucular symbol on in black in front of
it and it's sort of got the the words
covered on it it should say fallout
shelter and but here it's kind of being
covered in smoke to say all hell yeah
and it's just kind of it's very
in-your-face it's a very recognizable
symbol and then it pulls out that you
say this guy's just putting it up in in
the middle of the street which is a bit
alarming obviously if you if you sitting
on a street most sorts but fallout
shelter symbols up yeah I mean I I was
reading a few annotations of its well
because I've always seen all hell some
people talk about it being all out hell
yes the smokes covering it is the O in
the U so you can't use it as an excuse
on the top at the top to say that it
says all out hell when it's it's
obstruction that the one on the bottom
because then otherwise it says all out
hell t which doesn't really mean
anything when you think about it well
it's funny you say that because again
you know there's a you know I don't want
to say that we're not making original
notes here but there are some fantastic
websites out there that analyzed this
book in incredible detail
helter is a word it's a Norwegian word
that means Heroes which is like that has
to be a coincidence I know Alan Moore's
a genius but look at that there's no way
he would have thought of that that but
yeah I yeah so we have you know the sort
of the the the biohazard sign there and
the smoke rising across and it's not
quite clear what the smoke is when you
look at it but then it's kind of like
you appreciate it's that young kid
reading the secret Rick reading the
tales of the black freighter and the
cigarette smoke enough and it kind of
makes you appreciate that angle like if
you look on that page one that that
great opening panel of the news vendor
in the kid and you kind of have to
position yourself almost below the kids
need to kind of see where the smoke
would run and it's just it's that level
I mean we always say this don't we def
but it's that level of detailed
perception that makes his book kind of
above most yeah definitely like there's
so much thought being put into into the
art that it's just
it really elevates it and it just other
comics don't compare on this level
at all no no no definitely not and yeah
we begin I mean throughout this whole
book one of the things that I love so
much about it is the juxtaposition
something's being said and it means it
means what it kind of means what it
means and then it kind of is alluding to
other things here so we have our first
taste in this book explicitly as well of
the tales of the black freighter and
without spoiling anything because
obviously were going to go through the
whole story as well I mean what do you
think about the fact that it's kind of
like this demonic pirate narrative
within the main story really like that
which to be on right like yeah I get it
it's just I get how it all ties into
Ozymandias but it's never read it's
always kind of be slowed the book down
for me and it's not really been a
character that I've been not interested
in and so when I've been reading the
book I've kind of thought well it's a
black throat freighter bits you know
getting through this to get to the main
plot and so I've not been a massive fan
of it yeah yeah I know I know what
you're saying I think kind of like both
as an illusion for a human does and also
you know the idea in a world of
superheroes comics of pirate based
narratives and this is yerevan force now
the actual story so it's kind of like
Alan Moore's always very skilled
whatever ya'muru he exists in and here
it's a lot more kind of you know gothic
really you know they talk about the you
know the salt keg lips and the gut the
goals eating their faults and I kind of
like the imagery but if you were to just
read it as one thing it's not the most
gripping narrative yeah I mean it's
fourth-wall breaking and it's kind of
more of a gimmick than an actual plot
device to me yeah just just didn't like
the news vendor character he's not you
know when I think of Watchmen he's not
the first person that springs to mind
and and the black freighter certainly
isn't so yeah just these sections I'm
not massively fond of
and I couldn't see why they cut them
from the movie to be honest um yeah so
it's just kind of plotting along for me
a bit yeah yeah yeah I go he's saying
you know again we have the juxtaposition
as I say and I do really like how it
says the ships black sails against the
yellow sky and then we have yeah which
is you know that's so clever like that
for me is genius because they're not
they're not manipulating anything here
if you look at that it does look like
sails across the sky like you get you
know you can't sort it on that and then
he says the vendor who I'm pretty sure
we get the name of the vendor in the kid
later I can't quite remember what their
names are at this point I don't think
we've told them yet but they are very
much in it like a Greek chorus to the
story like they do interact with the
characters but they're kind of you know
the commenting on the wider world and
stuff love that and you know he says you
know the headlines look things in the
face and then literally the black
freighter about the lines on someone's
heads you know and it yeah it's
ridiculous I like as well in the in the
third panel we see the missing writer
yeah that pays massively into the end of
the book yeah and so the the plot that's
going on so it's nice to see these
little hints throughout even even in the
mundane sections that there's still an
overarching plot to the entire thing and
it's just a really nice little detail
that really after you yeah you know it
the first time you read it it's gonna
mean absolutely nothing to you you're
probably not gonna pick up on it
but it's one of those things that when
you go back it's massively you know it's
a big Easter Egg for you mmm-hmm yeah
definitely and the writer is why I
looked ahead because I know he's name is
Matt Shea who at the end of issue 8 they
have the new frontiersman he's kind of
like the literature they have at the
back and there's the article on him I
don't know if this is the same article
within that you know most likely is but
that is just another just kind of wink
wink sore things obviously it has such a
crystalline structure this book so you
always go back and again on the news
venue as well you see how sick is dick
yeah you know talking about Richard
Nixon there and just sort of own on the
back of the black freighter the Veidt
method Adrian Veidt is there as well
yeah and you've got blimp in the
background as well
it's it's just there's loads of nice
little things that you know talk sort of
give hints to the bigger world and
what's going on and it's just kind of
grim as well if you look at the guys van
who's putting out the fallout show he's
got like he's are like 50 more signs you
know to go around the city and like you
know this is just worn of of many and
there is and you also see the Promethean
cab company as well I mean we can point
out these details forever because there
is one of the things I love so much the
universe feel so real in this book but
yeah I mean you know we've we've dealt
with giant brew men and owls and now
we're just in the news vendor which is
quite nice and this kind of intro there
and and pushing forward on to the second
page which again is kind of juxtaposing
loads and look at that word again loads
and loads of you know the black
freighter with the world's what I love I
see every goddamn front page in the
world I absorb information I miss
nothing and then absorbing information
is birds were eating is forts and
memories so I guess they are you know in
a way kind of absorbing information and
for me it's the kind of it's it's the
stuff that I've not seen before in a
comic book
I love how we see this kid read in the
comic book and we're over his shoulder
and we like zoom into the book itself
yeah like it's a very slick motion and
that guy still bubbling on but it's you
sort of getting pulled into this comic
book and it's just a really nice use of
the angle of it um I've also just
noticed there's a little flash symbol on
the bin as well yeah which I don't know
if that's been reappropriation
yeah there's just little hints about
comic books
I'm just darted about this this panel
I'm sure and I've just noticed they're
sitting above it something called the
Institute for extra spatial studies yes
which I don't know what that means I
think I think that does come back in the
sense of the the squids later
I can't bridge exact time but I get I
mean obviously it's Watchmen so it does
come back but yeah that that is involved
as well and I love how you know in a way
this this pirate who's stranded he's
kind of looking at us as readers as well
of staring out
piercing kind of look and when we get
close enough where it says he's a
survivor you can see the dots can't you
wear it daily like been printed so it's
kind of a you know it's letting you know
that this is a kind of fictional world
within a quote-unquote real world and
then into this real world we get a raw
shap entering and I like how Rorschach
in his face it's just underneath the
face of the Sailor like it's kind of a
nice comparison yeah yeah it's it's just
really like I don't know how I actually
wrote this because it's so well thought
out in in advance and yeah everything
works and perfectly especially with the
9 the 9 panel layout it allows a lot of
things to be repeated across pages and
books and it's it just this is sort of
ending here that you know keep an eye
out for for motifs of this comic
interacting with the the black Freya
comic and it's it's very nice it's a
very nice way to open it subtly to know
let you know that the two things are
going to be connected throughout the
story yeah and it's just it's just
really good and I love the way that
Rorschach he saw plays of being crazy
and which will obviously you know it's a
persona to distract from the fact that
he is actually Rorschach like this guy
that he's walking around pretending to
be now it is his mask yeah it's the real
Rorschach it's all an act that he's some
crazy homeless guy who thinks the end of
the world's gonna happen every single
day like the the news vendor asks also
so how is it gonna be then the world
today and say oh yes today for certain
and then in the next sentence he says
you'll keep my paper for me tomorrow
won't you so yeah he kind of he's given
away that he knows it's not gonna be the
end of the world because I would be
asking for the paper to be kept tomorrow
and it's just you know he's clearly
playing up the part that he's you know
don't take this guy serious he's crazy
and it's just a
nice inflection on on Rorschach's
crime-fighting methodology where he's
completely dedicated to this role of
being a vigilante and he's done it so
much that the way that you would think
is his normal persona is actually the
mask on winded way to say he's got an
alter ego yeah yeah yeah and he comes
back as well like he says you don't
forget which is almost a bit comical
like it's it's kind of and I love the
motion especially those six panels at
the top of page free of just him in the
vendor and you know you get to panel
where you get the one pail of him
pouring the coffee him blowing it you
see the sign coming back in and you know
again the kid in the corners all looks
up looks back and one of the cute little
things that I'm sure Dave Gibbons put in
there as well on the on the bottom left
panel of page free you can see the
coffee stain that's spilt on his coat
yeah yeah it's just like so much detail
in it you know that just to keep the
continuity of this it's just really well
it sort of reminds me of this phase
comic that I once read where it was just
a woman ironing a top so panel one she
was ironing the top panel - she's still
ironing panel three Allen shira's head
just popped in the panel and panel four
she the woman still that I didn't Alan
Shearer has fully fully in focus now
panel five he looks at the woman and
then a panel six he just punches a Rahab
it's big build up to like the very
random event I think the the VIS created
there clearly took inspiration from
Watchmen in again definitely these these
six panels so Alan was responsible for
the comic strip Alan Shearer likes to
women yeah I'm sure I'm sure and the why
I like is well with the comic is on
those bottom free panels so the second
panel is a close-up of the first panel
of the comic he's reading and yeah that
one's a second so
so if you want to read this story you
have to kind of go back almost and look
at that foot yeah which is a really cool
panel actually you can see him on the
bow and the birds around but we don't
get that we we just get the two we're
looking at and I think I think the cut I
think the coloring in particular in
these two with those purples and Pink's
it just looks so hellish doesn't it yeah
well in comics had to be colored like
that in the the 67 he's in 80s because
they didn't have the where they didn't
have the hex colors that we have today
so you know he liked the The Killing
Joke was a classic example of a comic
that it was colored a certain way and
then they went back and recolored it
using modern technology and it is nice
that they've kind of used that color
palette that would have been available
to them back then you know it's very
limited and that's why everything's kind
of sharp blues purples yellows and
whereas today you get more a lot more
closer to reality in what colors are
used on every character so it is it's
not just a nice little callback to it
mm-hmm and you know again full of cool
back says so we have the sort of the the
sailor from the black freighter clearly
already insanity is creeping in to a
certain extent you know believing that
you can gonna cover this inanimate
objects eyes and that's providing any
comfort you know to anyone and that's
that's quite quite sad in a way and then
you know I love how that the last panel
so so clearly what's said in that third
panel that we can't see we read still I
could not love her she had loved me and
then we get into dr. Manhattan here a
very I love this section where he's you
know you know that sense of just
humanity adrift really he doesn't
appreciate how [ __ ] weird it is that
he's not there and there's two of him
like and and and he says as well because
I you know I I thought you'd like this
what did he think was gonna happen I
mean not to be too crude but was she
gonna [ __ ] to dr. Manhattan's I don't
know yeah it's really weird and it does
tie beautifully into the black freighter
comment hope I could not love her regime
and and you know we go
dr. Manhattan makin love and it sees
minds elsewhere and he seems to just be
going through the motions of what a
relationship should be he knows that he
he has to have sex to be in a
relationship so he just has one of his
duplicates do it was he's actually
focusing on doing work it just doesn't
seem to care in its I'm skipping
you know massively ahead that they're
having an argument
Laurie threw that throws a drink at him
it goes through him and then he just
magics it back together it's more
focused on picking that up and making
sure that everything's still clean and
in order and rather than reacting to
this this argument he never seems to get
angry you know someone's shouting at him
shut up I hate you and he's just like if
you think there's a problem with my
attitude I'm prepared to discuss it you
know which if you're having an argument
with someone and you're going all out on
them like throwing stuff saying you hate
them and they just say if you think
there's a problem with my attitude and
prepare to discuss it it's just gonna
like push your buttons even more and
make it absolutely furious and it just
shows how disconnected he is from
everything that he thinks that's a
response yeah and it's just he's like
dr. Manhattan absolutely loved the
character but it's kind of hard to
really say when if someone was to ask
why do you like dr. Manhattan that
there's not really much there that you
can sort of say because what is his
personality it is just very robotic and
mundane and it doesn't he doesn't make
any jokes he doesn't really seem to care
about anyone all of his answers that he
gives in relation to humanity are very
cold and it's very strange that you know
people would love this character he sort
of the the Qui Gon Jinn
of watchmen where everyone
next qui-gon jinn yeah but why do you
like him
he's got absolutely no personal you know
what I mean yeah some says why do you
like Han Solo you go cuz he's a brush
you know he's an antihero he's he's a
lovable rogue he's got a he's got a
little charm to him you go why do you
like qui-gon jinn because like pony tail
yeah I mean yeah he's got a little
goatee and it's sort of the same with
dr. Manhattan where it's very hard to
describe why you like him and this
moment is sort of just a summation of it
doesn't have a personality really yeah
I'm appreciated I don't really like if
I'm just fascinated by him like I
figured I think it's a fascination yeah
I think I think you know Alan Moore
really has kind of like put forward the
Superman argument to the enth degree
here in in a great way and when you see
I mean again the 9 panel thing so concur
in here but that I love that middle
panel when she's just screaming and yet
you just get and like you appreciate
she's pulling the cover over she would
have been nude you know it's a very
intimate kind of thing that he's just
kind of devaluing there and I like the
the body language of the two dr.
manhattan's as well this kind of it's
hard to explain isn't there kind of
shocks they're kind of pulling away yeah
and you know and obviously he says as
well no we have plenty of time is the
first thing he says which you know
ironically for him you know that all the
time in the world exists on these on
these multiple points and they really
you know in a perfect kind of two pages
they get across this relationship of
these two so so well I don't know what
stimulates you anymore and he would
stimulate it kind of feels quite celeea
doesn't it yeah it's very clinical it's
very you know removed from emotion and
so yeah it's just it's clear that the
guy just thinks in binary terms rather
than on a human level and this is
carried over into the next page when we
go to change Slater who is dr.
Manhattan's ex-girlfriend and the first
thing she says is he couldn't relate to
me not emotionally certainly not
sexually and which we're now to be true
because we've just seen it
happen and so we instantly can imagine
what Jamie Slater's relationship with
dr. Manhattan was like and it seems to
be very repetitive
you know dr. Manhattan he's a character
who doesn't evolve he's constantly stuck
in this state he doesn't age and because
of that it doesn't change so it's
clearly his next relationship will
suffer from the exact same problems
yeah the deterministic lifestyle that he
can see is within himself to a certain
extent he can't change that and you know
I like as well we're on you know she
says he says I don't know what
stimulates anymore she says John please
okay just forget it I'm fine it really
it doesn't there's a pause you can also
see the other dr. Manhattan leaving in
that panel as well vism well-sculpted
her blue ass there yeah then she says
the word matter like detached which
again like stimulate doesn't it matter
if the kind of the idea of soul they're
coming into it and the idea of
precedence and when he you know
recreates that glass which I agree I
love that sequence I love the fact the
glass go straight through him which I
mean she should have expected really
like you know I mean it's what would it
have done but you see the two the two of
them don't they the one of them's at the
door being quite apologetic quite
emotional the other one is Stern and
creative in and is that divided within
him for always yeah definitely it's just
a way of showing that he really doesn't
care you know he's he's trying to be
apologetic but his mind still elsewhere
and not in the moment and how could you
mind ever be in the moment when you can
view all of time at once and you you
wouldn't be attached to anything
because you know you're not seeing it as
a journey he's seeing it all at once
it's it's like you know looking at a
jigsaw from fully constructed whereas
humans tend to work piece by piece and
it's you've seen the bigger picture but
you're not in there with the fine
details of it that's very poetic way of
putting a very profound and and then via
the next sequence I mean watch
as a book deal so well with time and age
and we have a lot of characters like you
know I'm thinking obviously Hollis Mason
and Dan and then you know we have Janey
here and her relationship to kind of
glory in the sense that she was the
girlfriend of that stuff and I love the
paneling here
I love how on these two pages the left
is her recounting the riot is it's
almost the same things happening isn't
it it's another partner of dr. Manhattan
kind of leaving him for what he is yeah
and it's just its history repeating
itself dr. Manhattan's not really gonna
care about that because he you know he's
not that connected with history but yeah
it's just it's a nice little way to give
information on both of their
relationships in one go
and I've also just noticed at the bottom
driving Laurey in the taxi is a woman
who later appears in the comic yeah as
one of the the news vendor characters
like if you say if this was a sitcom
then the news vendor would be like its
own set like you'd be like Central Perk
and friends we're in it she's one of
those bleed-over characters from that
yes yeah yeah she's very the the gun fur
of Richmond to it to certain extend
there and yeah yeah you do definitely
see a later and you know again I've just
got a praise that the coloring here I
think the curing is fantastic that kind
of it's that it's a similar color to
when watchman's reading his journal in
the first issue as well that they're
kind of like crimson very very vital
it's sort of powerful they're a John
Higgins I should say was the cholera on
this and you know he does a fantastic
job and there's all these little things
in what works a sunset of yeah you know
it's the Sun setting on their
relationship yeah so deep right there
yeah so it's a yeah just it's a perfect
colors for it really
mmm-hmm and she's leaving the special
talent quarters yeah just got a such a
kind of like military way of putting
like what they're actually got going on
there but you know I quite like that and
yeah and we have here the basis of the
sort of the main thing of this
the cancer conspiracy the I mean there
is I think that I mean okay so we know
that Adrienne had the sort of tachyons
and stuff but like why couldn't dr.
Manhattan envision this happening why
was he surprised when he was confronted
at TV studio I don't know where he does
say he has to go through the motions to
hmm
in later when love you know was skipping
muscle he had Belaya when Laurie finds
out that the comedians are father dr.
Manhattan says to her oh you're going to
tell me that you're sleeping with Dan
mmm and she goes well how do you know
that because no what and she goes that
I'm sleeping with Dan and he goes you're
sleeping with Dan and he sought-- has to
go through the motions as well he's a
very famous quote is that he describes
it as we're all puppets but I can see
the strings and so he has to go through
the motions of it as well in order for
that ending to happen
dr. Manhattan has to go on TV and yep do
that so it's kind of preordained get
there so yeah that's why I does it yeah
yeah no no and on the with janie
obviously she's an overexpress we see on
the desk how sick is dick which
obviously we saw in the first issue as
well just connects it all together
really well and this isn't like a deep
analysis or anything but it's quite
interesting that when you see Janey
returning to Dan's apartment in that's
the second panel of page 7 collects a
crossword that building but yeah like I
know doesn't really mean anything again
but like I just you know just kind of
like this then obviously the locks being
repaired
because of you know Rorschach prior and
you know we have Laurie returning to one
of the only kind of you know stable kind
of got friends she has here which is Dan
and I like the fact that the guy is from
the Gordian knot lock company which you
know in a way is kind of a reference to
Alexander the Great and Ozymandias
that's what as he's trying to do really
trying to solve a problem by being very
drastic in his action well yeah you've
got the I mean you've got the age
by advert on that page as well yeah yeah
for nostalgia where the quote is where
is the essence that was so divine which
you know you read that and you think
water [ __ ] so you already sort of
getting the this thing that you know as
you man dies thinks he's above everyone
else and he's just got his fingers and
everything like the the Gordian knot
lock company and yeah the guy's just a
big [ __ ] really yeah the I just I
just quote from this website that put it
very well
The Legend of the Gordian knot is
associated Alexander the Great with whom
Adrian is obsessed an Adrian solution of
cutting the knight in two of his sword
rather than struggling to yawn tie is a
classic example of lateral thinking this
thinking is what Adrienne uses to
conceive his plan when he feels it will
save the world from nuclear disruption
but not without the death of millions so
yet again Alan and Dave are popping a
few hints therefore ro and I love how
connected this world feels Rorschach
breaks the lock the next issue it's
being fixed Rorschach takes the sugar
the next issue you know he goes to make
money yeah it's not that it's just
I love League yeah it's just like
everything's really well thought out
like I just I would love to see Alan
notes
Alan was notes on not just how deep he
got into every single thing and you know
just little things that you don't have
to carry over are carried over I no one
would have missed that the sugar not
being there and in the lock getting fit
I mean Laurie could have easily have
just shown up but it's just the fact
that he's put all this effort in and
then he ties into the overarching plot
of the Gordian knot and it's just like
just so well thought out and you just
can't commend it enough mm-hmm yeah and
you know quite quite interesting that
the Laurie here is she says well dad Dan
says like you know I thought I'd see you
at the funeral but I heard you like to
visit your mother which obviously she
was teleported to the other side of the
country but you know here it's kind of
taking us for granted and one of the
things I love throughout these two pages
here where they're kind of comparing dr.
Manhattan to Dan and Laurie's
doing a lot of you know human physical
stuff he's making a coffee he's passing
a tissue he's pulling out a chair but
we've doctor my hand he's like you know
his clothes are like floating around him
and assembly and I just love it
yeah it's it really just is a complete
juxtaposition of it there's that word
again
yeah um so yeah it's it's just like
really just well thought out how things
are going to mirror each other and in
the same way that the black frame mirror
Rorschach you know Dan having it make te
wilds dr. Manhattan gets ready but he's
not moving all the clothes I'm moving on
him it's just really well done um and
you're just stuck with this clinical
feeling of dr. Manhattan and Laurie
obviously that she is a human so she
doesn't want that which is why she's saw
the company of Dan you know a know her
dating a normal man makes more sense
like everyone wants today a god but gods
are so far above everyone else that they
would be completely detached you know
Superman would not date Lois Lane he
would date Wonder Woman um just because
they'd have more in common they they see
the world from the same perspective
whereas Superman I don't think would
ever be able to relate with Lois Lane
it's the same for the Dark Knight you
know every everyone liked Rachel Dawes
in that but she died and you know Batman
ended up going out with Catwoman which
makes much more sense than him going out
with Rachel Dawes because Catwoman can
perfectly relate to you know they they
know what it's like to put on a mask and
go out and fight crime
um and as much as dr. Manhattan was a
crime fighter he wasn't really like you
know Dan Laurie were were in the midst
of fighting crime dr. Manhattan just
waved his hand and people died and that
there was nothing that could really
oppose him and so Laurie of course is
going to have much more
a connection with Dan it's it's strange
that she ever went out with dr.
Manhattan in the first place but
obviously there was an attraction to him
being so powerful but she's lived with
it so long she's realized that the
relationships never gonna work yeah and
you know it's really nice as well like
you see this in a lot of alan moore like
he can get sound really well like I
think her crying you see that uh-huh
like you know anything dislike that
certain assortment of words I think a
really really well done and and you know
this happens in every episode that we do
we realized something that we've never
seen before and something I've never
seen before is when the kettle's being
poured in the middle of a page 9 you can
see vite you can see I DT so it's like
even like the [ __ ] kettles of this
world Adrienne is kind of you know
expanding itself to and you see Laurie
her silhouette in the kettle which I've
not noticed before over and I guess I
don't know this this might be a little
bit kind of year 9 GCSE poetry but
because she's crying and the water's
coming out the cat or you know maybe
could be seen as that book and sorta I
will calendar as well yeah yeah yeah
yeah giving it away he's like Batman
he's gotta have a bat on everything
you've given it away stop merchandise
and everything I there's something quite
like I I don't know if this is in the
film but I would I know this meant to be
a TV show of Watchmen coming out maybe
but they should definitely use the image
I think it's very powerful of dr.
Manhattan looking at that bra
yeah because it's such a kind of because
I love how in the background you see a
sort of celeea structure and a bra is
kind of similar to that in a sense it's
just kind of like you know a weird shape
kind of thing that and and it's kind of
he's looking at it we've almost like
befuddle man you know I mean it's so
different from what years exactly and
it's like the only clothing that he
picks up and everything else just kind
of comes out to him and him putting down
that bra is also symbolizing that he's
letting go with this woman I love how
you know Laurie doesn't really like
break up with dr. Manhattan she just
leaves mm-hmm
like normally you know it would be
polite to say aye we're finished it's
over Laurie doesn't even give him that
because she probably knows that she
doesn't need to he's so detached from
everything that you know it wouldn't
make a difference whether he says where
oh where there she says we're over or
not and you know you see you kind of see
when he's pulling all the clothes out
well you know it's the it's the socks
it's the shoes it's the cufflinks it's
this entire kind of thing folding around
him it's a crazy image oh yeah I love it
and you know I love that he kind of cuz
it's almost I don't know could it could
talk to Manhattan if he wanted to just
click his fingers and he's dressed
you don't even it almost feels to me
that he's actually dressing himself yeah
we're kind of going through the motions
of it which is what he's doing in in the
comic itself you she's going through
though it's a bit like this podcast you
know with oh it be fun but it's not and
we'll just going through the motions
we've got a lot like she's like to get
through but we'll grit our teeth a berry
and we have you know in the next issue
kind of a classic image are in cinema
the character kind of looking into water
staring into the reflection and kind of
you know pondering and you know we have
dr. Manhattan as well in the mirror kind
of you know what does he see is it is it
like what an animal looks in a mirror
they don't actually recognize themselves
I don't really I don't really know here
but we learned that Dan is is going to
visit Hollis and and Laurie he's just
gonna basically leave behind as well and
you know she talks about cabs you know
they get you from A to B and then we see
dr. Manhattan kind of you know disappear
and I love that shot of him in the ABC
studios and then the people are just in
complete astonishment yeah I was a bomb
going off to them like they're just
sitting there at work and it's just a
massive flash of light you know
everyone's got paranoia that there's
going to be a nuclear attack and for
this guy just blasted you would be
definitely startled and everyone sort of
just like going wild just falling all
over the place people stop vomiting it's
just yeah it's just you would just be
scared and the fact that dr. Manhattan
is no
consideration for how people would react
to this just shows again how little he
cares mm-hmm
like he's taking it so literal isn't he
like he could have just gone into an
alleyway or on the roof or something but
he literally comes to the entrance just
bang he's there and you know then again
face the contrast here they're not
paying me enough to handle monsters from
outer space and then we see this cinema
you know and obviously this is a kind of
a reference to to what what's coming up
later in the show you can see as well
when Dan and Laurie you can see the
Institute for extra spatial studies and
I think you can see here you can see the
I didn't know if you can see the the new
sky in the comic book in in the
background as well so there's kind of
thumb I saw online actually I have to
fly you straight in this way yeah yeah
it seems like they just all takes place
on this kind of square you got killed
further down that road then that's a
news vendor then Rockefeller centers at
the bottom by the street and then the
prisons at the bottom yeah I'd like
Adrian ice fortress is just off-screen
like you do yeah it's just next it's
just next year that's just cold poor
town I love how the the realism of this
world you know your your blue is far too
light for television yeah and obviously
he can adapt it and then you see this
guy's face of all that my god you know
and it would be astonishing as well not
only to see someone teleport but to
someone change their skin color in a
matter of seconds yeah and I just loved
the the alien poster that's used to
advertise the cinema on this page as
well because you know he would seem
alien to everyone and it's it's just the
world of fantasy that people you know
that wouldn't accept it if it wasn't
happening right in front of them yeah
yeah no and again we have you know
Laurie and Dan we get to see kind of you
know what sort of fight as they were up
until this point we've seen Danny who
watches the Watchmen written in graffiti
whoo yeah yeah and again I think Frant
big tire thing you never see it fully
you know no you never see in in its
entirety in the book and but it's always
kind of there in the background
you're filling in the blanks of it yeah
and just be getting to this fight
sequence then which is like I really
like how vicious they do fight like you
see Dan in that second panel kind of
like thrust two fingers into those guys
eyes Laurie like that they're decent
fighters yeah definitely in it's very if
you watch the the cinematic version of
it it's very gory um and it is sort of
hyper violent and and that is captured
perfectly here as well and to just beat
the [ __ ] out of these guys like one of
them's on the floor holding his arm like
screaming and yeah the the clearly can
handle themselves and I love the way
like they get backed into the corner and
they just look at each other and Dan
puts away his glasses and they clearly
the know they can handle this
and it's just you know it's it they're
bringing the old guns back out and also
gone on in this that they make a joke
that the TV presenter he says oh what's
up doc or something and in dr. Manhattan
just doesn't get a joke yeah at all
because up is a rough ship so that the
prisoner goes what's up doc and everyone
laughs and then goes up is a relative
concept it has no intrinsic intrinsic
value you can say right okay so let's go
into the questions so again it's just
shown that dr. Manhattan doesn't get
humor he's completely detached and you
know he it's just really nice I love the
way that it's just just opposed again
and I would we're Dan and Laura fighting
you know girls and they're getting back
into the habit of things and the I think
that when they look at each other they
realize that this is what makes them
feel alive mm-hmm it's sort of similar
to the Dark Knight Returns in which we
all have this yearning within us and you
know that there is something that when
were younger we love doing and as we get
older it's off
lips away from us in our priorities
change and you know that is always that
yearning to get back in and do something
even if you have the self-doubt that
you'll never be able to do it again and
it's sort of their moment realizing that
they can do it and they're not washed up
and it's just yeah it's it's just a
great moment yeah the whole let's try
and keep it snappy as she snapping his
arm yeah you know whatever it is you're
super people do and it's the context of
the world as well because I say walking
to the TV studio you know one of them
says like the no-go areas Afghanistan if
it arises you know play cool the first
question that's asked is about
Afghanistan yet so there is you know
this kind of yo geopolitical context too
as well and then we get you know Doug
ruff from the Nova Express who we see
earlier interviewing you know document
hands past squeeze their Janie and we
get this get this cancer plot and he's
going through you know he mentions he
mentions Wally Weaver who newspapers
called him dr. manhattan's buddy I don't
know if that was a reference to Bonnie
Barnes he was always known as Captain
America's buddy like so maybe it was
enough Bucky Barnes Bucky Barnes yeah
but he but he was always kind of like
paired as that like his Robin you know
what I mean like like he was always kind
of caps buddy like I remember I used to
read like all Captain America stuff that
was like a rich like terrible I think
they really like you know real dated
stuff but you know even so you know he's
bringing up this past anything he says
like you know Jacobi as well Moloch has
cancer during the six the thing is
though what surely dr. Manhattan would
have like incinerated more look like how
could they have had battles I don't
really yeah I don't know it would be
honest maybe we just didn't see him as
as big of a threat or you know he wasn't
murdering people he was just doing like
he was like a mad scientist I don't we
don't know yeah I let a lot live and
wait no no no it was the Minutemen who
took down Moloch wasn't it it was and
you remember this is the Ennis in the
next issue which is again majorly dr.
Manhattan there's that there's that
picture of him blowing that guy's face
off in that Club yeah Moloch is there
right ears so I mean yeah they would
have had some sort of interaction there
and you know all of this is kind of
building towards the inevitable climax
when they're kind of swamp in these dr.
Manhattan issues it's kind of hard to
see what the Nova Express is like reason
for doing this is other than for just
crate to sell newspapers you know what I
mean because well there might be
oh I mean do you know what the Nova is
does that tie into Osmond Dias darling
yeah he could own that newspaper the guy
the guys wearing a big purple jacket and
a purple tie in a yellow shirt he's got
a yellow badge in the yellow hair and
purple and yellow or white and color
palette so it's probably certainly
hinting there that you know Adrian Veidt
owns this this newspaper mm-hmm get on
Google what Nova means yeah I'm pretty
sure you're right actually now that you
mention it yeah because it makes sense I
mean he owns newspapers he owns kettle
companies that yeah the guy the guy has
his fingers and all these pies and what
I like with Dan and Laurie is like kind
of one of the common themes of this is
like especially dan you know he's a bit
too old he can't perform which will kind
of exploring later issues but you know
they hold their own they beat the [ __ ]
out of these guys yeah and I'm just
looking at what Nova means now right and
it's when two new stars brightly fade
together and this causes of flare up
that creates a new star so it's sort of
highlighting that these two stars of
Ozymandias and dr. Manhattan are sort of
in you know they're on a collision
course basically yeah he's height and
color as well doctor and adds to the
agitation doesn't it like yeah he
doesn't look as calm as he normally does
yeah is that the lips more angry and
just the way the kind of the panel's
like if you if you look at that that
page 15 where half of it is wordless you
know it's them just recovering getting
their breath and in a sense dr.
Manhattan's trying to get his breakfast
or but he's been mobbed by these people
like he's not really
saying very little you can see all of
these cameras all these microphones
pointed him him trying to get everyone
away and then on the next panel he
screams leave me alone and you know
teleports everyone away yeah he finally
loses that he finally shows some emotion
and you know it's captured on TV going
crazy I know I never really when I
watched the film I didn't really
understand what was going on at this
moment of him in the comic it's a lot
clearer though they just you know he
just gets rid of everyone in the in the
same panel they say sort of empty its
carrying on from Dan and Laurie's
conversation about how they always feel
once the adrenaline wears off they
always feel sort of empty and now dr.
manhattan's teleported everyone away and
he's feeling sort of empty as well again
the same the same structure I mean
actually looking at it now I've not
really considered this but if you go
pretty much all the way back to page 11
through to page 16 they've all got the
same structure where half of it's dr.
Manhattan half of its Dan and Laurie and
they've all got this kind of but it's
very cool structure where it's kind of
like almost an interlocking jigsaw piece
if you I think this book is [ __ ]
astounding in so many ways like you know
I think I think it's it is a work of art
for sure and this is nonchalance as well
like they've just killed them not killed
but like really badly damaged these
people and they just kind of walk on
pace I guess this is to them routine to
a certain extent yeah hundred percent
and they just come back to their life of
the realized or what we're probably too
old for this we need to just you know
forget about it
yeah and it's just it's quite like sad
but there's still the hope inside of
them there's that thing itches and any
return I love how and this dance walking
on the street is silhouette sort of
looks like an owl
yeah and it's it's just once again you
know he's walked away from this life but
it's it's it's very similar to those
Star Wars posters for the Phantom Menace
when he was in walking along and his
shadow was Darth Vader I don't know why
no one went oh your shadow looks like
darker than I am but here it's a lot
more so
oh yeah I always actually really liked
that poster yeah it's quite effective
wasn't it or shadowing force
foreshadowing or shadow and yeah dan is
returning to old man Hollis where yes we
spoke about before the whole repair shop
analogy is is great and you also see a
poster there for the new frontiersman
which is the magazine that was adverts
that the Rorschach boys that had the
match shave think so okay this is the
[ __ ] great figure out Watchmen it has
to know for expression new frontiersman
to different cuz new frontiers but I
like pro dr. Manhattan so it's like yeah
and it says like it caught it's kind of
hard to make out what it's saying like
you know it's you're right or something
or do the right but obviously right wing
is painted underneath there as well
which is good honey and I guess if you
want to get mega-mega metal like wings
or a commons or super everything
although no one can fly in Watchmen I
guess dr. Manhattan can but not anymore
rotella poor isn't either's not like yes
Mothman might have been able to glide
maybe but um we don't really say that
but yeah we doing Dan gets back to
Hollis and they're kind of you know
watching the footage that we've just
seen player and it's just a little
things here I love how next to the TV in
the bottom of page 17 you can see the
six-pack but there's been a can taken
away and then the cans in his hand
there's a little bit of liquid where the
cans gone and you can see his dog by the
fire as well III says before I love
Hollis's little thing I think it's quite
an interesting environment you know and
it's sad when he gets brutally made yeah
but it's just so well done like you know
this book it's won the Eisner Award it
won the Hugo Award it was listed as one
of the hundred best english-language
novels from 1923 to present by Time
magazine yeah and I'm gonna give it a
little award now myself I'm gonna give
it the bloody official definition good
graphic novels that you should read win
as nominees award so you can put you can
print that on the cover as well Allen
printed on in bold so well done you've
done it
and we learn at the start you know that
the Nova Express is being held for Ally
tradition of course this is why you know
it's all a very sort of well-planned
thing here and I like how when we see
the issue delivered on page 18 the band
of string is a crosses eyes which makes
him look a bit more menacing yeah and
it's just like it's got cancer on it as
well and cancers obviously it's a
massive trigger word isn't it it's a big
fear inducing thing and in all place in
it you know as human diets alienate and
dock from the public I don't know if I
mentioned it 75 times yeah right yeah
but I've been ill this weekend and you
know you give a little Google of the
symptoms about 70 different things come
up that it could be the one that stood
out was the bloody one that said cancer
I was like all of you have got good you
can smoke and that says on the internet
so it must be true and it's just like
it's such a fear inducing thing and it
would if anyone tells you you know if
anyone says this gives you cancer and
massively makes you wary of it and it's
it's very slight it's clear adrian
veidt's pot is in the background of this
book throughout the entire thing and
he's just using all of his available
means to derail what the public think of
dr. Manhattan mm-hm and we have your
favorite tale returning we're just no
continuity floor right here or might not
be it might be genius you can actually
see in that when the news when there's
getting the paper you can see down and
laurie in the background no I'm just on
so if you go back to the page where Dan
and Laurie are walking on the street
with a news vendor mmm you can see the
news vendor in the background of that
panel doing the same motion that he's
now doing in this panel can you seen it
from the other perspective with Dan and
Laura
walking down the street I mean even the
cars in the same position that the
people are posed in the same way and
it's nice that you know if you just flip
back and forth between the two pages you
seen it from the same scene play out
from a different angle
mmm so it's obvious that you know that
there's something going on with time
yeah
Adrienne had all these issues already
printed and lighting ready to go out
yeah yeah yeah which because if if the
time was synced up correctly
Ozymandias sorry dr. Manhattan was
appearing on TV just as this was getting
delivered and so yeah it's very it's
very sorta like pointing out that
there's something someone's planning the
ending of this before you know I mean
before yeah it's yeah nice I mean the
biggest biggest kind of news story in
the world would be going out and doing
this of course if there's any more
information on it it's gonna sell like
hotcakes
another yeah another thing I just
noticed back onto page 16 when Dan and
Laurie just leaving the alleyway you can
see one of the guys getting up in the
background kind of a silhouette of him
you know I mean perhaps that's one of
the one of the guys they're just beating
up who knows but um yeah and then we get
obviously get a bit more you know black
freighter in here as well and I mean
this kid loves to Black Friday he's
always bloody reading it like you nobody
pays for it no no not a library you know
we see quite a drastic change as well
from this moment to the end of the issue
where the news vendor becomes a lot more
you know warmer to him as well because
he realises quite you know someone who
reads the news knows how quite serious
it is that dr. Mann's being accused this
that he's gone vanishing and you know a
little bit of irony as Alan Moore loves
to do on page 19 where you know he's
walking up to his door and the the got a
paper door singing to the police classic
walking on the moon yeah and it's it's
nice that this sign this fall out sent a
sign
from the start as well as come back know
that fallout sound from the beginning is
now getting painted on to dr.
Manhattan's dog with danger quarantine
area it's like everyone now is convinced
that dr. Manhattan gives people cancer
which obviously you know the if you
thought about it it's not the case like
how many people must not a matter
interact with every day but is you know
but the public consciousness always
focuses on the negative
like I mean I mean just look at the
Islamophobia that that surrounds
everything today we'll all know that you
know Muslims aren't terrorists but
there's plenty of people who say stuff
like all Muslims are terrorists and just
because of like the acts of a couple of
people and now that's sort of it's a
commentary on that it's saying the
public will believe anything
even though there'll be millions and
millions of examples where people have
spent a lot of time with dr. Manhattan
and not call cancer and it's just sort
of playing at the fear like they went
when dr. Manhattan's walking along that
corridor the guy yelps when he notices
him yeah he says wow yeah I'm Josh
Manhattan you know pops back in his room
which again seems very sort of right you
know you're the most powerful man in the
universe you know he's just going back
to his rooms chill but there but then he
very quickly leaves realizing kind of
you know what's going on and just
heading off the first of all to Arizona
no mosque and I love how we've seen him
vanish earlier in the issue where he
vanishes and was just kind of like
Spectre you know like kind of like
specks of dust like but here he seems to
like melt and Ginter yeah The Wizard of
Oz yeah
clothes just sort of like crumble on the
floor yeah yeah I don't know why he's
done that but no no me neither and that
that guy is just kind of I mean he just
a sort of grunt isn't a and he just kind
of here this is this is crazy
you know you regular kind
[Music]
it's been raining every issue there is
so much talking so much information to
take on board and I love the fact that
in these next two panels when dr.
Manhattan returns where it's not quite
clear if you've obviously readings for
the first time why he's going back out
he's made much more care in the second
issue but and fourth issue sorry but um
we see him returning back to this test
space and it's quite beautiful isn't it
him walking through the ruins grabbing
the photo clearly looking quite sad when
he looks at the photo yeah well but it's
the last you know it is last human
memory I think that's a deal a it talks
about that was the last photograph of
him when when they bury him that there's
nothing to bury but to just have this
photograph and it's all that anyone ever
has of him and you know it's his lust
it's a the last capture of his humanity
and he's just looking at it longingly
but he knows that it's never gonna be
like that again and he sees Mars and
he's just smiles at it and then he
disappears and the way he is there's no
dialogue yet on these two pages at all
but there's just such emotion conveyed
yet completely and you get to see as
well in the bottom right the beech tree
is what the bars call which again we
will revisit later kind of thing and the
way he disappears as well in that middle
on that Ridge kind of looks like Saturn
with the ring yeah it's it's you know
he's he's going in Estella and stars not
a woman that he's called it's it's like
a space term I'm for you guys to learn
at home and you know just just something
about the image as well of just the two
of them and you know he does kind of
look unrecognizable like I don't know if
this is the first time again cuz I've
read least so many times controversion
do you actually see what you look like
as a human yeah yeah it doesn't really
point out that that's him yet the first
time reading it you could just be like
looking out I know it's just when pictu
is the random photo his smile and it's a
stock image
that they didn't know each other before
that fall but yeah yeah it's just a nice
little nice little tie back to his
humanity and there there is a if you
look at the the sign which is upside
down there's actually a Latin phrase on
the sign which says perda lorem ad astra
which says which means through sadness
to the stars we know quite quite literal
sort of common tree here and it on the
nose more it's like it's interested up
because it's in Latin bit on their nose
may expected more back I'm taking away
that official definition good graphic
novels you should read nomination award
I'm taking it away and there is we see
also in this photo frame this this the
phrase at play admits the strangeness
and charm and a basically a quark is a
type of subatomic particle and a you
know major constitute of matter there
are six types of quarks which are
coupled into three pairs one of these
pairs is known as to check the charm
strange pair so again it's just Alan
Moore's majorly intelligent he always
gets in these great references to things
and kind of puts them into a very subtle
artistic way and you know yet again I
had no idea around at quarks thing but
it but it makes perfect sense and the
only dialogue we have here which is more
again significantly importance of it the
story is black freighter which kind of
it's amazing the black freighter can
comment on anything like it's just this
one story but whatever's going on in his
story you know it kind of goes really
and the black freighter guy is talking
about sleeping beneath stars and you
know the kind of the idea of thinking if
something was really there or not and we
see a star kind of glimpse and off he
goes really and you know we don't really
see dr. Manhattan right at the end as
well here and yeah and to me the the
issue could have ended there to be
honest and but it goes on for four more
page yeah I agree there isn't too much
more to do in this issue we see kind of
Rorschach return we get a lot of the
black freighter yes on this issue just
completely dry about this point yeah
yeah III get what you're saying there is
um you do see which I've just seen here
at the
for page 22 the new frontiersman
headline our country's protector smeared
by the Kremlin we're you know let's you
know that new frontiersman a pro
Manhattan whereas Nova Express suppose
we get you know the quarantine guys
going into Lori's room and we see the
bra as well going into the VAT which are
quite yet yeah but yeah you know we get
a lot of total context they were this
guy's saying the linchpin of America's
strategic superiority has apparently
gone to Mars and I'd love had the
brother blaming her they know what he's
like like it's not because of this fight
yeah they pretty much had her to sleep
with him and she'd been doing a good job
so far but now she's left he's got
absolutely no reason to stay so yeah
it's it's it obviously the blame is
gonna fall on her in the US government's
not going to take blame themselves that
they've made a mistake they're gonna use
someone as a scapegoat and we get a
little bit you know I mean I mean three
panels worth of Rorschach which is you
know kind of if you would have been
reading this story again you might fall
I see that main character up to the
several main characters in this
storyline he wakes up Dan you know he
still feels an obligation to his kind of
theory about people killing superheroes
people kind of framing them in a certain
sense this is co hearing with what he's
saying we get a bit more black freighter
I like how the black the black freighter
ends and we get continued next month
kind of weave in it it's quite quite
cute yeah yeah and little comic guy
angry that it doesn't have an ending but
you know a very famous quote from
Watchmen is don't you realize Adrienne
nothing ever ends which dr. Manhattan
says at the end yes yes yes so yeah it's
just it's just pointing it out here as
well you know comics don't have an
ending in this welcome here Navan nd no
and that's kind of the finger Watchmen
isn't it we're spoilers obviously
probably know it as well where the diary
being delivered in the final panel
signifies a way bigger second you know
what I mean like I'll just contradict
everything but that's the beauty of it
that it knows where to end like as you
say things don't end but you
put the thing in and then you know 28 26
and 27 we get a lot of kind of focus on
again the geopolitical aspect you're
very scary really like at the time of us
recording this issue this episode
actually apparently North Korea of
created a h-bomb so I was sort of going
over this as that news was going on in
the background I wish dr. my dad was
real yeah me too yeah but luckily we've
got Donald Trump you next best thing
Donald my Hatton yeah yeah he'll so
he'll sort that out for everyone which
is so not worried about that anymore
and so yeah that's gonna be great mmm we
see you know he's a bit like a zoom and
eye doctor well Donald Trump is a
billionaire who's made himself selling
everything he'd sell you ever notepad
with Trump written on it you know what I
mean you sell your toilet paper with for
your Trump's written on it and Easter
everywhere and he's so become a
political power so you know Watchmen
it's still it still stands up today
because you know the idea is that it has
within never really go away there's
always going to be the other that you
know at any second could bomb us and we
need to be vigilant against them and
it's just I think that's why this comic
stood the test of time so long is
because it's so politically focused and
politics seems to just repeat itself all
the time mmm yeah completely and you
know this um just a nice light kind of
clever writing as well where Nixon's
inform that he's gone to Mars and thinks
that if you wanted to stand a red planet
you should have stayed home you know in
reference to the Soviets yeah and kind
of what's going on there which i think
is really really nice as well
and i the guy at the bottom of page 26
is actually Henry Kissinger Secretary of
State so there's a lot of just kind of
you know clever references here going
through and you see Nixon is smoking the
cigarettes that most people smoke here
or the cigarette holders to have that
like ball on the end like which is just
again watchman always has these things
that are slightly off from the real
world and you know symbol heavy so we
begin with these bio hazards
honor honor like on the wall of a city
now they're plastered over the map of
America like yeah it's kind of ramping
up to an incredible State gang
juxtaposed similarly in structure with
the free buy freedom free buy free of
you know dan and Laurie fighting and
dogs man here we have dr. Manhattan on
Mars looking very happy you know looking
very peaceful you wonder why the way
from not having to pretend to be too
attached to anything he's finally got
his wish of being fully removed from
everyone yeah and he just kind of looks
at the photo for a last moment and then
kind of looks not quite at us but kind
of above us like I wonder what he's pond
is how I looking out into infinity isn't
he - a Sonic's then wait not that he's
looking at Burger King on Mars there's
Burger King on the Mars and he's just no
it's delicious looked at my world like
some episode of Lost yeah discover
something at the end I'm only joking
with you guys I won't need you again
maybe I think you know I think up to
this point in the book he's sort of
wanting to be alone from everyone and
now he's got his wish
he's sitting on that on Mars and then he
looks at the photo and then looks back
up and he's like oh I got my wish but
you know be careful what you wish for
cause now I thought I do feel a bit
lonely I've sort of lost my humanity
maybe it's it that realization that he's
happy that he's alone but then he looks
back to this this younger version of
himself who that that guy didn't want to
be alone he was with a woman he was
having a great time and he just so you
know he he misses that bit too bit so
I'm gonna stop crying a bit it's like
you realize because as I say earlier he
gets called the linchpin he's left for I
don't know what the time is not a long
time you know maybe 12 hours nuclear
Wars about to kick off like ya know he's
the one holding it all together and you
know you would have fought if someone
knew that the neighbor just okay my
opinions on now I'm more you know six
million people counting on me
it doesn't really care
clearly what he cares about is is the
past to a sign extend this photo which
again is a bit mysterious when export in
the next issue and we have this big
panel which again you know it's all that
mirroring isn't it because on the first
page this issue we get the we get the
big panel with the free above it which
is a news vendor in the fallout shelter
we get the fallout symbol again at the
back in this case he's looking at the
photo though so they mirror each other
which is you know mirroring in Watchmen
we all know is done on an expert level
and the final quote as well which we get
the title of the issue from so a quite
like how issue one to Bob Dylan quote if
you choose an Elvis Costello quote if
you freeze the goddamn Bible yeah
really roughed up here you see I don't
know he's meant to get that quote but
it's the best it is it is isn't it yeah
really kind of you know shall not the
judge of the earth do right and it feels
quite you know just the kind of that
clipped language feels quite biblical
and it's asking an open-ended question
that you know on it if you ask that you
know one can answer that apart from him
really yeah yeah and this it's just you
know it's very ambiguous ending to the
issue and you left kind of feeling like
what's going on what's gonna happen and
I mean just before we get to the the
final part which is obviously the
literally and I have to say the issue
for might be might be my favorite issue
the whole see yeah the best just in my
opinion is that the fearful symmetry
well yes yes the basically dr.
Manhattan's origin in life yeah I'm
certain are sorry it's not I'll tell you
why it's not the best one and whatever
one fearful symmetry is which I think
might be issue six I think it's yeah
that's the best one okay okay oh yeah
that's all yeah yeah your mouth that's
got a lot of black freighter in it but
no I know what you're saying
structurally and it's all it's more
about Rorschach that one as well
yeah yeah next one come in it's
definitely and certainly in the movie
it's it's definitely one of the most
interesting parts of the film oh yeah
yeah I I think it's probably the best
part of film actually yeah I am it's
done really well actually it is done
really well but and again we get more
under the hood in the background which I
just read through for went on you don't
get too much information here you sort
of you learn that Sally
Mary's the sort of promoter for the
Watchmen and then obviously
they split up after and he sees with
cheats and comedian it has as daughters
oh we get the McCarthyism which is
rampant in you know Hollywood at this
time as what everyone calling each other
commies and I like how captain
metropolis and Hollis because of their
military and police records are kind of
kept as clean Mothman he's investigated
because of his left-wing friends and
Hollis you know prospects that perhaps
this investigations because they were so
ruthless led him to be under pressure to
develop a drinking problem
and how did justice is mentioned as well
now this isn't now this isn't mentioned
in this volume here but apparently
comedian killed hoodie justice yeah
in the the Mayfair games role-playing
game which alum or co-wrote there is a
module called taking out the trash which
basically states the comedian shot him
you know and and because I think because
of what happened when he was trying to
rape earlier on and that it was revenge
essentially yeah and yeah there's still
that mystery surrounding it obviously
you know Hollis Mason it's written from
this book to written from his
perspective so if he knew the comedian
killed it you were right it in the book
but he doesn't know that so that's why
it's not you know written in black and
white here and but it's just sort of you
know inferred that something bad
happened to hooded justice and Alan wah
he never puts anything in a book that
you can't solve and you know if you
think about it there's only one person
who we've seen who didn't get on with
her to justice so it's pretty easy to
draw the conclusion there especially
knowing how Alan were rights so yeah I
think it's yeah it's definitely him and
you know lots of interesting stuff
towards the end of this section as well
Hollis mentions a Red Cross benefit that
we see quite a lot in the series when
the older what Minutemen meet you know
the crimebusters two Watchmen whatever
they called and you know especially like
the section where he talks about dr.
Manhattan and meeting him I found him to
be a little distant maybe that was more
my fault than his though since I found
it very
very easy I think I found it very
difficult to feel easy around the guy
even once I got used to the shock of his
physical presence it's a strange thing
the first time you meet in your brain
wants to scream blow a fuse and shut
itself down immediately refusing to
accept that he exists which I'd be a
really kind of sums it up brilliantly I
think because like yep you know if you
meet God
it just contradicts your entire reality
doesn't it yeah it's gonna give you an
easiness and just a feeling that you
know we've been replaced I think he says
we're not the God we're not superior
anymore there's something above us but
you know he also realizes that nothing's
impossible and I just love how they talk
about the superhero fad it's sort of
similar to like the superhero movies
today you know it's sort of seen as a
fad and you know it's just nicely just a
really nice chapter and I you know
to me this is about passing on the
mantle and he says you know superhero
stuff was dumb but to me I take from
this that he's glad that someone wants
to carry on the legacy and I take that
from just the way that he mentions so
expected junior in it and you know he
says he's surprised that someone wants
to borrow and follow his example the
name night-owl and follow his example as
a crime fighter and he said Halle says
he always thought was a dumb name to
begin with but there might be a new
Knight out patrolling the streets in New
York so he infers that he thinks it's
it's a dumb name you know he never took
that the part that seriously but he says
in the following sentence Sally Jupiter
says that little lorries when she's old
enough she wants to be a super heroine
just like a mom so who knows it seems
far off from being a novelty nine-day
wonder the superhero has just become
part of American life it's here to stay
which sort of infers that you know he's
very humble he'll never confirm that he
thinks that it's a nice thing to do and
but just from the way that he talks
about
other people doing it it clearly does
hold it in high regard yeah and yeah he
mentions just retiring to the garage
which off CBC in kind of you know Vega
he says that he was twenty three years
behind the mask as well so you know a
long time that he was a night owl in
that regard as well and yet he says I
love what you do yeah what you said yeah
the super has become part of American
life it's here to stay for better or for
worse which here obviously quite ominous
Aaron you kind of have these two age of
superheroes with with the Minutemen and
the crimebusters
and you've got to think that there
wouldn't be any more superheroes
probably they can't really be after dr.
Manhattan can they and it's just like
what's the point they wouldn't yeah you
know they're not they're not fulfilling
anything but um yeah that is that issue
free which which again is crazy good
issue maybe I agree maybe some of the
black freighter stuff it's still good as
dressing but I think narrative wise it's
not as propulsive and and definitely the
next issue and fearful symmetry issue
five are just crazy in terms of the
story but um yeah def any closing
thoughts on this issue it's been a good
issue for better or for worse
I'll get that I think I've been here any
I look up and then uh I'm just sitting
in my house now I'm just looking about a
Burger King right talk to me yeah like
Watchmen should have done a time for bug
king when they had the film out like
toys and stuff but I can imagine that
would that that would have gone off but
yeah no I agree I mean obviously this is
one of our favorite things ever so it's
always a joy to talk about I want to
urge people as well subscribe send us an
email watching The Watchmen pod at
gmail.com get in touch with us in the
comments you know we'd love to hear from
you tell your friends about this show as
well you know because we want to get as
many people as possible it's still early
days we still got a lot of issues and
this will be here forever so maybe
you're listening after Korea drop the
h-bomb and we're all little people but
you know it's it's all good really and
um tell us what your favorite episode of
The Watchmen is please please please do
that that would that is fan engagement
ads finest but um definitely think of
Watchmen very common right a 5,000 word
comment
what you think you want to see in the
Watchmen right well no and I guess
finally if you've got a you got a
patreon having you the moment you know
it's just there in the background I
realize you can hide the the donation
amounts
you can't hide how many people are
signed up to it but you know just don't
look at that zero yet look yet I'm gonna
tell you now you bet I would sign up to
it and you better give me all your money
so whatever you get paid every month I
want that in the account otherwise I'm
gonna find your naki out because we've
only got ten listeners on this show and
I know who's listening and I'll find you
and I'll kill you
really massively helps out you know just
I just say what if you wouldn't if you'd
dropped a penny in the street you
wouldn't pick it up would you so just if
you send us a penny a month you know 100
people do that I'd get a pound
and you know it just goes towards
graphic novels like
I've done I think 100 graphic novel
reviews on my web site in the past year
and and you know 100 graphic novels in a
year that they're about a tenner each so
you work it out yeah how much is that I
have them so [ __ ] many man I you know
I know it's getting quite bad sometimes
I just started slowing it down because I
just think I'm posting so many all the
time that no one's gonna read them but
you know I've had this is the first
month I've hit 5,000 website visits so
really happy with that
thanks very much it's probably cuz this
is about million reviews on there and
you know there's obviously I'm gonna get
some people viewing it but yeah thanks
very much everyone he checks out the
website that's definition car at UK with
two F's and yeah and just if he if he
can give us you know 20 pence a month
make my please please yeah I mean I've
got a now I've got a patron as well and
so if you another many think donate that
one don't donate that one yet get in
touch of us is the main thing Watchmen
all that good stuff
thanks again ma'am yeah cheers thank you
very much do donate to that one because
Tom there's a lot of really good stuff
tell you what if you feelin generous
donate to make me and Tom Gilbert 20
cans each that'll be massive make
massive thank you
you